there is gonna be a new iphone it's
coming there's actually gonna be a
couple of them uh let's take a look at
the first one this is the rumored gold
iphone 5s it's gonna be gold people and
it's on a fancy red stand there i don't
think that's gonna come with it apple is
expected to launch two new models uh
that's gonna be the 5s right there it's
going to have fingerprint technology and
then they're going to release a cheaper
version in many many colors uh that's
going to have a plastic case and uh
then uh you know there's gonna be some
other fancy things siri is gonna be a
little bit better and we'll get a faster
processor and all that three might be
off of the cheaper version siri's not
gonna be on the cheap sheet that's what
i read
yeah that's right she don't come cheap
that's funny
i could be wrong because a i don't know
what i'm talking about b i don't care no
but i have a feeling that that might be
one of the things they take out to make
it cheaper you heard it here first
people series off the plastic one um so
what i want to talk about with this is
do you guys think that apple has started
to lose its cool factor is it starting
to happen you know when they really were
coming up and they did that 1984
commercial and they were fighting the
power and they were going to change the
system and they basically defeated pcs
and now they've become such this big
monolith and steve jobs isn't there
anymore and it feels very corporate and
they show commercials that look you know
everything's so wonderful and then it
says you know designing uh cupertino but
uh they don't show you the sweatshop in
china have they lost a little something
to you guys well the sweatshops china
are what make it so depressing i mean
it's wet yeah i think that you want the
sweatshop i want them in the commercial
i think those would be moving yeah for
sure i don't know i feel like now with
the 5s it's just what we don't know what
more colors fingerprints
and that is exciting
but what else is there no i think
they're a little i yes are they a little
less cool because other people have
caught up which was inevitable you can't
stay ahead in this there's you know why
because they're smart guys everywhere
yeah and those smart guys i you know i
haven't i've seen the guys with the
galaxy or whatever and it's also cool
yeah
you know if there are a lot of cool guys
then the first cool guy seems less cool
you know but i mean i'll get a 5s by the
way my my iphone 5
broke your iphone 5 yeah it's okay you
just can't talk on it other than that
okay so all right so that's that goes to
my next point so your iphone 5 broke i
have uh an ipad i have a macbook air i
have an iphone blah blah they all have
ripped frayed cords i went into the mac
store uh the apple store last week and
uh the guy accused me of doing uh the
phrase was something like you're you're
abusing this in a in an unnatural manner
or something
yes i'm abs i hang myself and and you
know it's like some kind of auto erratic
i mean their stuff does fall apart
because it's being made in china but
you're going to keep buying it and
you're going to keep buying it and i'm
going to keep buying that's this i guess
i went through three ipads from november
to december ipad ice pad
three three ice pads
nothing i would get it home and the the
charger wouldn't fit in the thing or i
would get it home and it would just shut
off and i kept having to take it back
and they kept replacing it and it was
like i thought this was supposed to be
where this didn't happen it wasn't crap
what i like is that so my iphone 5
it just it you can talk on it but it it
the free as soon as you touch it to your
face it starts freaking out and it'll
dial numbers or it'll mute like it's
impossible so i had to use a cord but
it'll still mute like so i'm just trying
to make a phone call just text yeah
that's the first problem so i call uh i
call them i get them on the phone and uh
i try to explain the problem and he's
like well you got to do a hard reset i'm
like yeah but i don't i got i don't want
to do a hardware stuff because i got
stuff on there that stuff right and he's
like i'll put the cloud i'm like all
right i'll figure i'll ask my girlfriend
she'll tell me um and i got everything
on the cloud basically um but then he's
like have you uh dropped the phone in
water i'm like no i didn't drop the
phone in water oh yeah i forgot to tell
you and then and then and then he's like
oh have you dropped your phone i'm like
dude i've had a phone for 14 months yes
yes i've dropped it i've dropped it like
eight times yeah i drive it all the time
but everything else works like the
internet works everything else works and
the conversations themselves are so
exhausting that it wears you down but
what i find interesting is that i'll go
to that apple store and you got a guy
who was accusatory yeah right
immediately who said like you did you
[ __ ] your phone
you know it's really handy sticking it
in your phone right and and then
but i've gone and sometimes they're like
oh that's too bad let me get you another
one yeah like and i don't know i don't
know how
that happens sometimes they just give it
to you
well i don't know how they do it but
interestingly what he said to me when he
was at first it didn't appear he was
going to replace any of my chords and i
said well you know i have the macbook i
have the ipad and the blah blah blah and
he said you know one of the things we do
here this is the manager he goes one of
the things we do here is we have to
treat everyone the same
and i thought this is
first off that's socialism but but also
we shouldn't have to treat everyone the
same because if i have all your [ __ ]
well then i should be treated a little
better than the guy that walked in and
bought you know or that has one ipod
from 20 years ago and it's a thing that
guy thinks he's saying something nice
but what is essentially he's saying is
you've been a loyal customer and i don't
give a [ __ ] he's pulling the old you
know if you bring cupcakes at your third
grade birthday party you have to bring
cupcakes for everybody because if you
bring cupcakes for three people well
then i uh very quickly i go to meet my
girlfriend and baby when they came back
from a trip to the midwest when she
returned to work just last month uh and
so they're uh coming off the plane and
they got the nanny and the baby it's
like traveling with the rolling stones
in 1982. it's like the some girls tour
and so and i and i sneak up to the top
part not through security but right on
the other side of security just so
they'll see me so i can then help get
down and i'm waiting there for like
eight minutes thousands of people come
off the plane it's her plane eventually
she's gonna come off and i've been up
there and then there's no one else there
no one else there and of course then not
a tsa guy but like a tsa manager comes
up to go sir you got to wait downstairs
i'm like i'm just they're coming right
now i told her i'd be here uh it's my
wife and my and and baby and the nanny
and i got so much stuff and i just want
to see you guys well if i if i let you
up here i let everybody up here and
literally i'm like
there's no
nope here's that you let me up here
you're just letting me up here that's it
that's it that's all there is thank you
but i lost that fight yeah because you
can't get her because the second like i
went back and forth two or three times
and then i think i'm in an airport yeah
don't don't don't you gotta you gotta go
down that's what they say you can't
fight city hall you can't fight apple
and you can't fight the tsa